dans la jungle amazonienne
aux premières lueurs du soleil
comme un rituel chaque matin les femmes
les hommes les enfants vont se baigner
dans la rivière
yalu coûts et sa famille sont des kiss
est j'ai des indiens d'amazonie selon
leurs croyances ce bain matinal ne sert
pas juste à se laver il permet surtout
de purifier le corps dans l'eau sacrée
de la rivière
l'eau de la rivière elle est vitale pour
lui on y va le matin car cela enlève
toutes les saletés de la nuit
cet ol a toujours permis à notre corps
de ne pas tomber malade et de rester en
bonne santé boire
cette eau sacrée ces indiens se lave
avec il l'a bois quand ils se baignent
grâce à elle ils ont su traverser les
siècles loin de toute civilisation
mais aujourd'hui cette existence est
menacée
au village des kiss et g elles ne sont
que quelques dizaines de familles aviv
leur tribu fait partie d'une des
dernières communautés indigènes du mato
grosso
tous vivent sur un territoire protégé le
parking ou et tous se battent contre un
ennemi qui les encerclent
car leurs réserves ressemble aujourd'hui
à une mince langue de forêt entourée de
champs de soja
mais même à l'intérieur de leur oasis
ils ne sont pas à l'abri car la
déforestation alentours a dénaturé tout
leur environnement
[Musique]
dans leurs rivières qui se remplissent
elles aussi de sable l'eau devient plus
trop
or ces rivières était jusqu'à présent la
principale source de nourriture du
village
comme leurs ancêtres c'est à l'arc que
yakou et les siens chasse le poisson
mais depuis quelques années les prises
se font bien maigre de carlo sablonneuse
empêche de repérer les proies
comme ça et c'est la couleur de la
rivière change avant c'était propre on
pouvait voir les poissons
c'est vers ce pays là ça fait combien de
temps qu'on cherche ses conseils avant
c'était pas comme ça on arrivé en
courant on encerclé le poisson et on le
tuer aujourd'hui c'est plus beau si la
vie en inde je ne
mangeais dollar et le poisson le plus
nourrissants pour les indiens devient de
plus en plus rares
mais la pêche qui diminuent ce n'est pas
le seul impact de la culture de soja sur
la qualité de l'eau au village d'autres
signes inquiète bien plus les indiens
dans cette rivière si cruciale pour leur
survie iai coûts et les siens continuent
de s'y baigner et de la boire mais ils
se méfient de plus en plus de leur peau
depuis quelques années il ya de plus en
plus de gens se plaignent de
démangeaisons
ça les grattes après s'être baignés
alors les gens sont de plus en plus
inquiet
parce que plus haut là bas sur la
rivière il ya tous ces champs de soja et
on ne sait pas trop ce qui le met dedans
une eau polluée par le soja c'est la
crainte de tous pour eux le soja qui
pousse si près d'ici aurait apporté un
nouveau fléau
des produits toxiques
une chose est sûre
pour faire pousser plus vite ce soja on
déverse des tonnes de pesticides et
d'engrais chimiques dans la région
alors comment savoir si ce soja qui
nourrit nos poulets a un impact sur
l'eau et la santé
aucune étude scientifique n'a été
réalisée au ching ou
en revanche des analyses ont été menées
dans une autre ville du brésil entourée
elle aussi deux chambres soja
et leurs conclusions sont édifiantes
elles ont détecté la présence de
pesticides en grande quantité dans l'eau
dont par exemple l'endosulfan un produit
toxique interdit dans l'agriculture en
france depuis 30 ans or ici sa
concentration atteint 0 82 microgrammes
par litre dans les puits d'eau potable
ces 80 fois plus que les seuils admis en
europe de telles doses engendre à terme
des cancers qui trouble neurologique et
hormonaux
aujourd'hui le brésil avec un milliard
de litres de pesticides déversées par an
en est le plus gros consommateur au
monde un risque sanitaire qui aurait de
quoi inquiéter au plus haut de l'état
[Musique]
pour en avoir le coeur net nous prenons
le chemin de brasilia c'est la capitale
nous voulons savoir si les autorités du
pays sont bien conscientes du problème
ou si au contraire elles ont choisi de
fermer les yeux
au ministère de l'agriculture
voici d'herlies dossa c'est le premier
conseiller du ministre celui qui a lancé
la culture intensive du soja selon der
lido ça c'était l'un des meilleurs
moyens de sortir le pays du marasme
économique
quand on parle de l'agriculture du
brésil on parle d'une agriculture qui
aujourd'hui est capable de nourrir ses
190 millions d'habitants et qui
exportent presque dans 200 pays dans le
monde
un succès économique mais au prix d'un
réel risque pour la santé des habitants
nous présentons au conseiller du
ministre ce document de l'agent
sanitaires brésiliennes basilienne et
surveillance et interviennent une liste
de quatorze pesticides reconnu comme
dangereux et que la chance voudrait
interdire dans ce pays comme cela est
déjà le cas aux etats-unis au canada ou
en europe
auto interview nous interdit aux
interdits en europe des recommandations
que pour l'instant le ministère de
l'agriculture tarder à appliquer vers
son blog woods qui est écouté si dans un
pays tropical comme le nôtre toda vous
enleviez tous les produits chimiques
utilisés au brésil à ce propos la base
nous aurions évidemment une chute de la
productivité très important en boîte et
on doit s inquiéter sur la production
des aliments dans le monde
s'il vient à manquer de nourriture il y
aurait beaucoup plus de gens qui
mouraient de sous-nutrition qu'à cause
de l'utilisation des pesticides
pour produire et vendre chaque année ces
millions de tonnes de soja le brésil est
donc complaisant avec l'utilisation des
produits chimiques